[Musique]
bienvenue enfin il ne rentrait presque
comme les autres sur le campus de paris
saclay une rentrée en présentiel voilà
qui redonne de la vie et de l'animation
au territoire autre excellente raison de
se réjouir l'université paris saclay est
une nouvelle fois distingué par le
prestigieux classement de shanghai un
palmarès qui répertorie les meilleures
universités au monde l'université paris
5 et se hisse au 13ème rang devant
toutes les autres facultés françaises
alors cette réussite elle est liée à un
projet qui marque cette année ses 10 ans
la loi du grand paris a permis de faire
émerger ce cluster unique en son genre
une exposition permet de revenir sur
cette histoire avec cette regards
croisés cette regard d'artiste c'est une
exposition itinérante et votre
territoire ne cesse de changer paris
saclay tv vous fait découvrir de
nouvelles liaisons piétonnes qui vont
permettre de connecter le plateau de
paris saclay à la vallée et on vous
propose une halte au domaine de cordet
ville un lieu historique qui est donc
maintenant ouvert au public les familles
ont pu re profiter de nombreuses
animations cet été mais ce n'est pas
fini d'autres rendez vous sont prévus
nous verrons à la fin de cette émission
dans notre agenda évidemment
chaque année il fait et défait les
réputations des universités mondiales le
classement de shanghai reste
incontournable dès sa création
l'université paris saclay s'est classé
dans le top 20 elle se classe
aujourd'hui au 13e rang c'est la
première université française et ce
n'est pas du tout un hasard comme nous
l'expliquent thierry doré vice président
recherche et sylvie pommier vice
présidente adjointe en charge du
doctorat de l'établissement
[Musique]
venir c'est paris saclay est classé dans
les 20 premières depuis 2020 donc depuis
la première apparition de l'université
paris-x sacré dans ce classement
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est apparue
directement dans les 20 premières parce
que c'était le moment où on a commencé à
considérer la façon dont fonctionne
réellement l'université paris saclay
c'est à dire
l'université en elle-même issue de
l'université paris-sud les
établissements composantes qui constitue
l'université paris saclay et les
organismes de recherche et les
universités qui sont associés à
l'université paris-x sacré
antérieurement tout cela a été vu de
l'extérieur notamment au niveau
international de manière segmenté
fractionné dissocier maintenant on
regarde cet ensemble là comme un tout et
ça n'a rien d'artificiel puisque ça fait
très longtemps que l'ensemble de ses
institutions travaillent ensemble y
compris avec les organismes de recherche
qui pèse la moitié en gros de la
recherche faite à l'université paris
saclay et du coup on a fait un bond dans
le classement de shanghai entre la façon
dont étaient classés individuellement
notamment l'université paris sud et
maintenant la façon dont est classé
l'université paris saclay est évidemment
l'université paris saclay qui représente
dans une certaine mesure une partie de
la recherche et de la formation
française est très heureuse d'être
classé dans ses 20 premiers
le classement de shanghai s'est quand
même d'abord un classement recherche et
c'est vrai qu'il a probablement plus
d'impact pour les diplômes recherche
pour les chercheurs en général donc
niveau master doctorat
on a entre 40 et 45% de doctorants qui
sont étrangers la première aire
géographique dont ils viennent c'est
l'asie c'est un endroit aussi où on a un
impact plus fort je dirais ou regardent
plus attentifs à ces classements là donc
c'est un impact j'irai sur
l'attractivité vis-à-vis de ces
étudiants-là qui viennent soit pour
venir en master soit en doctorat ensuite
dire est que au delà d'avoir des
retombées en termes de satisfaction ça
fait toujours plaisir d'avoir une belle
reconnaissance je pense que c'est
surtout des retombées en termes de
visibilité et d'attractivité en fait il
ya vraiment un enjeu c'est être dans les
20 à 25 noms que les gens arrivent à
retenir et quand on arrive dans le dans
le top 25 le top 20 ça permet en fait
d'être très visible à l'international
cette année 2021 marque une date
anniversaire il y a dix ans la loi sur
le grand paris a permis de faire émerger
ce cluster unique en son genre pour
marquer cette date le pea paris saclay
vous propose une exposition itinérante
part exacte les paysages pour revenir
sur l'histoire et les enjeux du
territoire cette regard d'artiste sur un
projet hors norme première étape le
château du val fleuri 7 à gif sur yvette
nous avons rencontré benoît lebon
directeur de l'aménagement et laura boda
adjointe chargée des affaires
culturelles
[Musique]
cette exposition est née de la volonté
de marquer les 10 ans de la loi du grand
paris puisqu'il ya dix ans la loi du
grand paris a lancé le projet de cluster
scientifique technologique et
technologique de paris saclay
l'établissement public a souhaité
marquer le coup en choeur en événements
et on sait on s'est beaucoup interrogé
sur la manière de faire et finalement on
a décidé qu'il pouvait être intéressant
de faire un pas de côté un peu par
rapport à notre métier d'aménageur et de
et de réfléchir à comment on pouvait
montrer ce territoire d'une manière
différente notamment avec des regards un
peu un peu décalé et doué d de là est
venue l'idée de faire cette exposition
et puis on a voulu également que cette
exposition soit itinérante
c'était très important pour nous que
cette exposition puisse aller à la
rencontre des habitants et des usagers
des territoires et c'est pour ça que là
aujourd'hui on est on est à gif sur
yvette et que cette exposition va se
déplacer à guyancourt à versailles sur
le campus urbain pour aller à la
rencontre des habitants
[Musique]
cette exposition paris saclay est un
projet audacieux dans lequel s'est lancé
le pea nous sommes très fiers d'être la
première ville à recevoir cette
exposition elle permet de découvrir
paris saclay sous un autre angle et de
réconcilier si besoin la nation c'est
l'art
le paysage permet d'illustrer la
dynamique du territoire ainsi on peut
identifier les différents types de
population les paysages variés de notre
territoire ainsi que les styles
architecturaux
le château du val fleuri était une
demeure du ca la ville ensuite acquis
cette propriété donc c'est un peu une
suite logique aujourd'hui de recevoir
cette exposition est en plus d'être les
premiers à la recevoir
[Musique]
un territoire en constante mutation et
qui ne cesse d'être aménagé je me trouve
sur l'une des deux nouvelles liaisons
piétonnes qui vont permettre de relier
le quartier de moulon à laval et au rer
b l'objectif c'est une meilleure
circulation c'est aussi d'éviter les
cheminements dit sauvage nous avons
rencontré sébastien moisan chargé de
projet sur la zac de moulon est chargé
d'opérations sur les liaisons plateau
vallée et christophe del mar lui il est
paysagiste
[Musique]
utilisons pas togolais donnant entre la
zac de melon et la vallée de l'aude
olivettes sont situées sur un site
classé et ce site du coup est régi par
l'état directement et par la commission
des sites qui détermine si le tracé si
le projet si les matériaux sont
adéquates par rapport à l'environnement
du site les travaux ont des mauves ont
démarré ont démarré en ce début dans ce
début septembre ils vont durer six mois
pour la première liaison puis six mois
début 2022 sur la deuxième liaison qui
donne davantage sur bures-sur-yvette la
première donnant sur orcel l'objectif de
ces liaisons est avant tout de créer un
lien entre la zac de moulon et le
plateau sacré et la vallée avec
l'université paris 5 et l'autre objectif
c'est de converger les flux piétons sur
ces deux liaisons et éviter des
cheminements sauvage pour permettre le
reboisement du contre ainsi les
chercheurs les habitants et les
enseignants de l'université perdre ses
clefs de la vallée du plateau pourront
commencer à utiliser ses liaisons à
partir de l'été 2001
ces deux liaisons sont donc
manière d'anticiper aussi les
développements du plateau puisqu'elles
vont relier dès à présent universités et
les grandes écoles mais aussi les
quartiers d'habitation qui viennent
d'être livrés puis à terme le métro et
tout le développement de l'ess du
quartier ces liaisons s'inscrit dans un
grand système effectivement deux sites
classés en même temps ou si toute la
vallée de chevreuse et tout un grand
système de pare aussi urbain c'est à la
fois un milieu naturel un milieu urbain
d'où la difficulté de réunir à ces deux
éléments à la fois de conforter des
usages qui sont celles d'une métropole
et en même temps et milieu naturel donc
c'est tout l'enjeu tivement de ce projet
on a mis en place
un vocabulaire extrêmement simple qui
reprend le vocabulaire des liaisons qui
existe déjà sur polytechnique ou sur la
vallée de chevreuse avec un vocabulaire
de grands en marche mon oncle a qui sont
pas en grès qui sont des blocs
effectivement préfabriqués en béton mais
qui sont posées comme ont posé autrefois
les boeufs gras et sur du sable et puis
de grand pavé degré de récupération dont
qui sont directement issues finalement
des coteaux qui était exploité jusqu'à
la fin du 19ème début du xxème sur ces
liaisons
[Musique]
enfin ne ratez pas le chemin qui vous
mène au domaine de corneville un lieu
historique
ouvert au public depuis le mois de
juillet cet été les familles d'orsay
mais pas seulement avaient rendez vous
sous le soleil exactement
tout de suite les précisions de
véronique france tarifs adjointe au
maire chargée de la culture de
l'animation événementiel et du
patrimoine
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est pas une journée unique
quand même ça s'inscrit effectivement
dans un programme qui avait lieu tout
l'été qui s'appelle sous le soleil
exactement et qui a été organisée en
collaboration par la mairie dorcel amel
mjc d'orsay l'ensemble des associations
la participation de la cps et
l'établissement public du plateau de
saclay aussi l'idée était de proposer
des activités à la fois festives
ludiques et culturelles à l'ensemble des
anciens avec sans doute un focus un peu
plus fort sur un public familial pour
pouvoir intéresser à la fois les enfants
mais et leurs parents donc des ateliers
qui permettent aux enfants de découvrir
de nouvelles activités et souvent en fin
de journée des spectacles qui permettent
à ce moment là aux parents aussi qui
trouvaient leur compte aux intéressés
j'ose dire et c'est un peu ce qui va se
passer aujourd'hui cette après midi on a
eu beaucoup d'enfants qui sont venus à
l'atelier jonglerie et ce soir à 18
heures on aura les parents qui pourront
participer bénéficient aussi de ce
spectacle et on a toujours eu un public
assez large avec toutes les tranches
d'âge qui viennent à nos spectacles
où on pense est important de pouvoir
proposer un programme d'activités à la
fois ludiques et culturelles aux or
c'est un sur un lieu en plus historique
qui n'a pas été investi durant les
dernières années et qui méritait que les
anciens puissent reprendre le goût et
l'habitude d'y venir parce que c'est
quand même un endroit assez exceptionnel
et demain en plus qui sera en plein
coeur de ville de coeur de ville
l'intérêt de corps de ville c'est d'une
part de délocaliser un peu si j'ose dire
les animations qui traditionnellement
ont lieu dans les trois quartiers
d'orsay qui sont le centre ville monde
et touré le guichet mais sur le plateau
évidemment il ya un programme très
important de développement sur ce
quartier de cordes ville qui est sur la
commune d'orsay et le fait d'investir
les lieux cet été redonne l'habitude aux
or c'est un qui parfois avait travaillé
sur le site de thalès qui étaient
implantés ici jusqu'à il ya quelques
années de revenir d'emprunter les
chemins qui montent depuis le guichet
jusqu'au plateau de faire un lien entre
le plateau de saclay qui est en train de
se développer de façon considérable et
le centre ville et de réinvestir les
lieux en profitant de toutes les
installations qui ont étaient proposées
et mises en place par le ps de visiter
la châtaigneraie et de profiter de ce
nouvel espace de vie qui est fort
intéressant et qui du coup d'une vie à
ce nouveau quartier de cordes ville et
fait le lien avec le reste de la commune
[Musique]
le domaine de corvil on va en reparler
dans un instant c'est notre agenda on
commence déjà avec la semaine de la
mobilité c'est à partir du 16 septembre
beaucoup d'événements prévus plus de
précisions sur le site pap.fr les 18 et
19 septembre ce sont les journées du
patrimoine
n'hésitez pas à aller au domaine de
corneville beaucoup d'activités sont
prévues notamment une journée bivouac
mais il y aura aussi une fanfare et du
cinéma en plein air l'exposition paris
saclay paysage je vous en parlais dans
cette émission c'est jusqu'au 26
septembre donc au château du val fleuri
à gif sur yvette mais n'oubliez pas
c'est une exposition itinérante
d'autres rendez vous sont prévus les
rendez vous sportifs à présent avec la
15e édition de la foulée cheney
courtoise c'est le dimanche 26 septembre
en solo en famille ou entre amis venez
vous défouler il y à des courses de 1 km
3 km 10 km donc aller sur le site si ça
vous tente le tout paris saclay 2021 là
c'est plus pour les amateurs de vélo que
vous soyez sportif confirmé ou simples
pratiquants amateurs de balades en
famille ou en solo vous allez trouver de
quoi satisfaire vos envies c'est le
dimanche 3 octobre la veille c'est la
nuit blanche nous serons le 2 octobre
installations expositions spectacles
place à l'image sous toutes ses formes
rendez-vous à la commanderie laissez
vous captiver par sept concerts voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi toutes les
informations sont sur le site le pap est
ce point fr vous donne rendez vous pour
un prochain numéro à très bientôt
[Musique]